all right so let's move on to the social
justice warrior piece of this because I
spent the last week watching a ton of
your videos I had seen many of them
before and you just do a great job
because you fearless leap put yourself
out there and as you've said repeatedly
already you're not representing anyone
other than yourself but you're talking
about some serious stuff you're talking
about Islam and black lives matter and
feminism these are these are pretty
controversial things so let's start with
well first off I guess when did you
realize what a problem the SJW the
social justice warrior stuff had become
was it directly related to the trans
stuff where had you seen those sort of
themes because of all the world of
tumblr and the rest of it well right
around the time that I was starting my
channel a lot of things were happening
in the media I don't know if you
remember there was someone named
Stephanie or Stefani um they were like a
trans ager it was like a 45 year old man
who identified as like a six year old
girl yeah I've seen some videos on that
yeah yeah complete degenerate and the
leftist media was pushing stories about
it and you know talking about how it was
brave and amazing I thought that was
super disturbing and then I was also
around the time when New York started
finding people for not using the right
pronouns and I was like okay these
people like I said earlier are fighting
wars that I did not ask them to fight
and I just wanted to you know speak my
mind about it and then you know there's
also other components as well I don't
like how feminism in sjw's tend to
completely ignore men's issues which is
one of the first topics I touched on on
my channel and how they have all these
you know apologetics when it comes to
Islam there's a lot of stuff yeah there
is a lot of that and it's all kind of
tied together so let's start with
feminism because you've been pretty
outspoken against feminism or at least
what feminism has become so can you lay
that out for me yeah basically I have
sort of an objection to the ideological
framework in which feminism operates
under which places women as an entirely
separate social class than men and place
women is sort of a victim status which
I've been around strong women my entire
life I've never found this to be true
that women are some sort of damsels in
distress and I actually think it's kind
of sexist to place them in that in that
place I also didn't like how feminism
you know move virtue signal when they're
confronted about men's issues and say
they care about it when they don't do
anything tangible to actually help men's
issues and help men so those are really
main objections to feminism right so
then you became a men's rights activist
and as a someone that has transitioned
and is a woman this really flips a lot
of things on its head because people
would think that you would be the
reverse for some reason I think that
would be traditional thinking but when
did you realize that you wanted to
become part of the men's rights movement
and actually first can you just describe
what you think men the men's right
activism what is it really because I
think a lot of people don't know yeah
yeah well first of all when I started my
channel I definitely you know waived the
MRA flag you know men's rights after
this fog I've kind of stepped away from
calling myself of that because I don't I
feel like sometimes when I label myself
or when anyone labels themselves they
sort of fall into the trap of
confirmation bias and I don't want to
feel like I have any sort of alliance
with any sort of groups I just take each
issue individually and digest it and
make my opinion for my opinion but I
definitely do care about men's issues
and I still talk about them on my
channel I it comes close it's close to
home because I have a half-brother who
has been to jail for domestic violence
and his wife had no scratches on her she
completely lied about it and she was
able to get him arrested just on claims
um I also care a lot about inequities in
divorce court at family courts male
suicide I don't like the stigma around
male victims of rape and molestation
it's kind of a lot of things there's a
huge crisis in education for men and
boys are falling behind there really is
a lot of issues on like I said the minim
just doesn't even touch on them they
claimed you but they don't right so I
think that sort of conventional thinking
on this is that men of
kind of been in charge of the world for
so long that even if some of those
issues that you just mentioned are true
you know claims and divorces and jail
and this and that that I sense that
there's a certain amount of people with
leftist thinking and some of these
social justice worries that would just
say well you know what suck it up men it
your time is over now obviously that's
not saying I subscribe to but do you
think that's where it's coming from with
them yeah but but I mean I think that
line of thinking is super dumb being
that there's the past and there's the
present and things change and people
have to change with it we have to
realize that there are issues that face
men now but they didn't think yesterday
and kind of move forward with that
because at the end of the day the
pendulum did swing too far and we're
kind of still in this state of trying to
convince people that the pendulum swung
too far yeah I would imagine that out of
all the things that you talked about
that this is probably the one you would
get the most hate for and we're going to
get into some of the other ones in a sec
but would you think that's fair to say
no I think by far the the biggest one
that I've gotten blowback from was black
lives matter really so not even Islam so
alright let's let's shift Islam for a
second so you just did a video that I
watched where basically you said that
being an Islamophobe is not a bad thing
and then you laid out a case for that so
can you kind of can you kind of break
down that video and then we'll link to
it below so people can get to it yeah I
mean my question would be like I'm
transgender why would I not be afraid of
Islam I mean like I said this video the
implications behind the word
Islamophobia as if somehow it's a
rational to fear Islam which is an
ideology that calls for my brutal death
I'm not sure why I wouldn't be afraid of
that I mean I would not be able to exist
peacefully in a Middle Eastern country
under Islamic law really I can only
exist in Western society where people
feel how they want to feel about trans
people there's definitely people who
wouldn't like him solely for that reason
but there is a general consensus that I
have a right to live my life as I see
fit and I'm not hurting anyone else and
that is what allows me to be here right
so when you're talking about this you
definitely to me are making the
distinction which I always try to make
between Islam which is just a set of
ideas that can be criticized like any
other set of ideas and people who live
as Muslims and there are plenty of
Muslim people who as individuals would
certainly not care or want to harm you
in any way or who might fall in love
with you or anything else or who could
be your biggest fans but you're saying
that we're we're the rules of Islam are
in place this is something that it is
legitimate to fear it is not phobic to
fear you're not you're not prejudging
your post judging yeah anywhere that
Islam is codified into law is a horrible
place to live in terms of human rights I
mean that's just an objective truth like
obviously there are exceptions but even
in those exceptions it's just not up to
par with the freedoms that you can have
in Western society um obviously I've met
many many Muslims who are perfectly fine
no issue the thing is I think you and I
agree on this like it's important to
separate people from ideas it's not you
know that you hate Muslims because
you're criticizing Islam it's just the
idea of Islam not the person who follows
it I mean look I always say it's like I
do not I would only judge people on
their individual feelings there you know
I mean if you're trying to behead me or
if you're trying to subjugate women then
I have a problem with you but if you
privately believe whatever you want to
believe whether it's in Mohammed or
Moses or the Spaghetti Monster or Jesus
or who else is there
it's by a couple other good ones right
yeah but that's the difference between
us and Ashley W is there the thought
police you know like it's not enough for
people to you know accept trans people
like in their own hearts whatever you
have to actively show it yes you know
what I mean like it's like everyone has
to be an activist or you're part of the
problem that really is the difference
you know yeah you know it's funny I saw
on real time a couple weeks ago Bill
Maher did an interesting piece about the
left and he was saying you guys are
always finding little dirt in a room
that you demand to sweep up meanwhile
the hall the whole buildings burning
down and I think that's really why
you're describing it's like you have all
these people who their general ideology
is pretty much the same but they're
finding little ways to fight with each
other as there's actual issues that
completely ignoring me in terms of for
all the trans people or LGBTQ people or
women or other minorities that are in
all of these places that are ruled by
Islam it's horrible for all of them but
I don't see anyone on the left doing
anything about that no absolutely and
it's just like you touched on I mean
it's not enough to accept trans people
and you know not discriminate against
them if you actually measure them you're
automatically a transfer oh it's in they
could be constantly I mean it's just in
the word of what they describe micro
aggressions absolutely microscopic you
have to search for it to find it if you
have to search for it it's not a problem
yeah so wait let's jump into the micro
aggression thing and trigger warnings
and take spaces and all that so I know I
know you're as against them as I am but
as someone that's younger than me did
you when did you see this actually
starting like when you were in high
school was this concept bubbling up
there because when I was in high school
it did not exist at all no I'm really
young I didn't even see you in high
school I thought when I got to college
that was when I tried seeing it I
started seeing you know it was like
everyone at my school had to be liberal
social justice warrior or you were kind
of blacklisted and it was kind of like
you know that's that person and we're
woke and we're you know constantly
bridging signaling and more great people
that's kind of what it was um I saw a
lot of bias in college classrooms and I
think it spawns in college more than
high school but but yeah yeah so what do
you make of going back to Islam for just
a sec that Islam seems to have been put
at the top of this oppression Olympics
that we talk about all the time so you
as it so trans is high on there but it's
actually lower than Islam to me the the
SJW people the the regressive people all
this their highest place in the
oppression Olympics is Islam which
actually is the most regressive and
against progressive ideals of all of
these ideologies so what is going on in
their well-intentioned brains absolutely
nothing Trump's Islam on the oppression
Olympics it it's really crazy how they
really are like you said completely on
the opposite
and what they believe in on pretty much
everything yeah yeah it I really I
genuinely don't understand it like I've
talked about this before like why is it
I think it's simply because they are
dumb enough to conflate Islam with brown
people and they found he pull at all
costs I think that's what it is I think
it's that simple they're brown
so they win which is which is not only
there's actually a degree of racism
related to that but it's also it's
terribly sloppy thinking because guess
what there are brown Christians and
there are brown Jews and there are brown
atheists and everything else so they're
attaching an ideology to a to a racial
connotation which is which is silly and
nonsensical and one of the things I saw
you know the Olympics is happening right
now and our friend Lalo tweeted out a
picture retweeted a picture that some
writer had posted and it was I believe
it was a woman from Iran and a woman
from America in beach volleyball and the
American woman I think it was an
American woman
you know she's it just in a bikini as
always well tan you know great body
bikini and the Iranian woman was in you
know the hijab and the whole thing and
the guy wrote something to the effect of
there's nothing wrong with this and and
Laura wrote something like well actually
one culture is forcing women to do that
and I thought this just to me is the
perfect example of the virtue signal
that I don't have a problem in and of
itself with this woman wearing that
stuff but it has to be purely her
decision to do so and she has to be just
as free to wear the bikini so that
American woman could wear a hijab and
cover up completely but she is the
choice to do either and it's just not
true that the other woman has purely the
choice even though in this specific case
maybe she did but I suspect not and and
this is the the crux of the problem you
think that's fair to say yeah absolutely
and people pretend like the job is you
know a choice over there and it's just
religious expression no they don't have
a choice and it's incredibly
uncomfortable I mean I would imagine
I've never worn one but I would imagine
to gets [ __ ] hot on for the hair link
it's not it's not as if you know it's
just a different culture I think some
cultures are
objectively better than others yeah and
I'm not saying you can't wear it but you
it should be up to you that's why it's
always women that are put in these
things right like that's true oppression
right it's not women forcing men to wear
weird things it's always been forcing
women so doesn't that show you a little
bit of the power play there yeah I mean
feminism is completely silent on you
know issues regarding women in the
Middle East which i think is insane I
think that the fact that that's another
one of my huge problems with feminism
they focus like you said on the small
little corner in the room of the dirt
and they don't focus on what's actually
happening you know like like who said
microaggression man's playing man
spending all this [ __ ] and women in
other countries are suffering it's like
they only focus on America and we don't
have that many problems here yeah not
God in terms of women and you know
oppression of women we don't really have
anything wrong yeah not to say we can't
get better at some things but name so
what did you make of because to me the
biggest example of what you're talking
about
was New Year's in Germany when there was
the mass sex attack and and rapes and
they're still trying to figure out what
happened in the media kind of covered it
up but it obviously turned out to be a
lot of the migrants and the new
immigrants that have come from Syria and
actually they've come from all over the
place because it's very unclear where
they're coming from because of some of
the laws that Merkel's placed in terms
of immigration but immediately I saw
people on the left not defending women
they were actually throwing women under
the bus but immediately defending Islam
now we've already talked about for
whatever reason they hold Islam at the
highest but isn't that the most anti
woman thing you could do women are our
mothers and our sisters and our
girlfriends and wives and their
immediate reaction was not to defend the
people who had been attacked but to
defend an ideology that had led the
attackers to doing it I mean it's just
the most backwards thing you could do I
mean it's a sickness it's this this I
mean I've read articles about you know
Swedish women who were raped and they
don't tell the authorities because they
know that the person who raped them was
a migrant and they think that you know
they don't want to contribute to racism
I mean it's a complete sickness it's so
wrong and I think that the idea like we
said I think this is
it's just the brown person thing you
know right now with everything black
lives matter in the media everyone is
rushing to defend around people at all
costs
and Islam they happen to complete that
with brown people
you